.
>> Sean: HELLO, FLORIDA!
HELLO!
HELLO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
GREAT TO SEE YOU!
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S IT!
I'M LEAVING NEW YORK!
[CROWD CHANTING U.S.A.]
ALL RIGHT, WE GOT TO DO A
SHOW.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE BROADCASTING LIVE FROM
BEAUTIFUL WEST PALM BEACH IN
THE FREE STATE OF FLORIDA, AND
IN JUST 12 DAYS, YOU'LL DECIDE
THE FUTURE OF OUR GREAT
REPUBLIC.
TONIGHT IN JUST A MOMENT WE'LL
BE JOINED BY GOVERNOR RON
DESANTIS, FLORIDA'S FIRST
LADY, CASEY DESANTIS WILL BE
WITH US.
ANY MARCO RUBIO FANS IN THE
HOUSE?
MARCO RUBIO WILL BE HERE.
SENATOR RICK SCOTT WILL BE
HERE.
RICK SCOTT FANS HERE?
ALL RIGHT.
BOTH DESANTIS AND RUBIO ARE
POISED FOR MASSIVE ELECTION
DAY.
GOVERNOR DESANTIS IS UP BY A
WHOPPING 14 POINTS IN A
UNIVERSITY OF NORTH FLORIDA
POLL.
THE SAME POLL SHOWS SENATOR
RUBIO UP BY SEVEN POINTS OVER
DEMOCRAT/RADICAL/SOCIALIST/LEF
TIST -- LEFTIST.
TONIGHT, MOMENTUM IS
ABSOLUTELY FOR THE
REPUBLICANS.
WE START WITH A LOT OF GOOD
NEWS TONIGHT.
IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO FLORIDA.
NEW POLL BY RASMUSSEN OUT
TODAY, YESTERDAY, HERSHEL
WALKER WAS UP BY TWO POINTS.
AS OF TODAY, RASMUSSEN HAS
HERSCHEL UP BY FIVE.
IN NORTH CAROLINA, THE LATEST
-- AND THIS WAS JUST FOR THIS
PROGRAM, INSIDER ADVANTAGE
POLL CARRIE LAKE UP IS BY 11
OVER KATIE HOBBS IN ARIZONA.
WE NOW HAVE A DEAD EVEN SENATE
RACE WHICH MEANS MARK KELLY
WILL BE PACKING AND HEADING
BACK TO ARIZONA.
BY THE WAY, TO ALL OF MY
FRIENDS IN ARIZONA -- WE WERE
JUST OUT THERE -- PLEASE
UNDERSTAND VOTING FOR CARRIE
LAKE, DON'T FORGET BLAKE
MASTERS.
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT SENATE
SEAT WE WILL WIN.
ANY WAY, SO IF YOU VOTE FOR
MARK KELLY, YOU'RE BASICALLY
VOTING FOR CHUCK SCHUMER.
I KNOW CHUCK SCHUMER.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO LIKE HIM.
THAT MEANS EVERY RADICAL
DEMOCRATIC POLICY.
MEANWHILE IN THE GREAT
LIVE-FREE-OR-DIE STATE OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE, CHRIS WILL BE
EASILY REELECTED.
IN THE STATE SENATE RACE,
RIGHT NOW GENERAL DON HAS A
REAL SHOT.
IT'S A ONE-POINT RACE.
HE CAN DEFEAT INCUMBENT
DEMOCRAT MAGGIE WHO HAS DONE
PRETTY MUCH NOTHING.
FOR THE STATE OF NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
THIS BRINGS US TO THE
COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA
WHERE AFTER THAT VERY
REVEALING DEBATE -- BY THE
WAY, DEMOCRATS ARE MAD AT
FETTERMAN THAT HE WENT TO THE
DEBATE AND PEOPLE COULD SEE
THE REAL CONDITION.
THEY'RE NOT MAD THAT LOST THE
DEBATE AND THAT HE WENT TO THE
DEBATE, THEY WANTED TO KEEP
HIM IN HIDING FOR A LONG TIME.
DR. OZ IS NOW UP BY THREE
POINTS ACCORDING TO A
BRAND-NEW INSIDER ADVANTAGE
POLL.
THAT'S GREAT NEWS FOR
PENNSYLVANIA AND WITH JUST 12
DAYS TO GO, DEMOCRATS
COAST-TO-COAST ARE ALL
STRUGGLING TO GAIN TRACTION.
NONE OF THEM WANT TO BE SEEN
WITH JOE BIDEN WHO EARLIER
TODAY ALONG WITH CHUCK
SCHUMER, THEY HAD WHAT IS
CALLED A HOT MIC MOMENT.
THEY WERE CONSOLING EACH OTHER
ABOUT THEIR PARTY'S VERY BLEAK
POLITICAL OUTLOOK.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> WE'RE IN DANGER OF THAT
SEAT.
>> LOOKS LIKE?
>> LOOKS LIKE THE DEBATE IN
FLORIDA AND PENNSYLVANIA --
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> Sean: THEY KNOW GEORGIA
IS SLIPPING AWAY FROM THE
DEMOCRATS AND FETTERMAN CAN'T
SERVE.
THEY'LL TRY TO PUSH HIM
THROUGH REGARDLESS.
THE DEMOCRATS WILL DO ANYTHING
FOR A WIN OR ANYTHING FOR
POWER.
IF THEY GOT THAT POWER, THAT
WOULD MEAN THE END OF THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
THAT WOULD MEAN CORE PACKING
AND D.C. AND PUERTO RICO
STATEHOOD.
EVEN IF IT HURTS THEM,
DEMOCRATS ONLY CARE ABOUT
POLITICAL POWER.
THAT'S TRUE IN FLORIDA WHERE
PROFESSIONAL POLITICIAN
CHARLIE CRIST IS RUNNING
PURELY FOR VANITY.
HE NOW COMPARES HIMSELF TO
JESUS.
DID YOU SEE THAT?
CHARLEY, YOU'RE NOT JESUS, OK?
FOR ALMOST -- HE'S RUN FOR
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE OFFICE IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA AS A
DEMOCRAT, AS A REPUBLICAN, AS
AN INDEPENDENT.
HE WAKES UP AND CHANGES ANY
AFFILIATION ON ANY GIVEN DAY.
IT'S KIND OF HARD TO PIN DOWN
ANY CRIST POLITICAL BELIEFS.
AT ONE TIME OR ANOTHER, HE'S
HELD ALL OF THEM.
CURRENTLY THE MAIN PILLAR OF
HIS CAMPAIGN IS CLIMATE CHANGE
AND CRIST IS NOW A
CARD-CARRYING MEMBER OF THE
CLIMATE ALARMEST CULT SO, OF
COURSE, HE'S IN FAVOR OF
LIMITING OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION, THE LIFEBLOOD OF
THE WORLD'S ECONOMY AND
DRIVING UP THE PRICE AT THE
PUMP HURTING EVERYONE HERE IN
THIS ROOM TONIGHT AND EVERYONE
WATCHING ON TV.
HE'S VOWED TO VETO ANY LIMITS
ON ABORTION INCLUDING UP TO
THE MOMENT OF BIRTH!
AND NOW --
[CROWD BOOING]
-- PRETTY TWISTED.
NOW AS ONE OF JOE BIDEN'S
BIGGEST FAN BOYS, CHARLIE IS
EXCITED TO BE A RUBBER STAMP
FOR ALL THINGS JOE BIDEN IN
THE SENATE.
IN THE HOUSE, HE VOTED WITH
JOE BIDEN 100% OF THE TIME.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
100%.
HE'S LIKE A PERFECT BIDEN
ROBOT.
RECENTLY, HE PRAISED BIDEN FOR
HIS EXCEPTIONAL AND PHENOMENAL
LEADERSHIP, THANKED HIM FOR
HIS WORK ON INFLATION AND GAS
PRICES.
[LAUGHTER]
AND NEEDLESS TO SAY, THE CRIST
CAMPAIGN HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
RECENTLY, HIS CAMPAIGN MANAGER
WAS ARRESTED FOR A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE INCIDENT.
ONE OF HIS CONSULTANTS WAS
ACCUSED FOR SENSUAL ASSAULT --
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
HIS RUNNINGMATE CALLED
HISPANICS RACISTS AND HAD
UNKIND WORDS FROM FIDEL CASTRO
FOLLOWING HIS DEATH.
CRIST WAS ACCUSED OF
SOLICITING CAMPAIGN DONATIONS
FROM HURRICANE VICTIMS.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT?
GOVERNOR DESANTIS SHOWED REAL
LEADERSHIP BEFORE, DURING AND
AFTER HURRICANE IAN AND THE
RECOVERY AND THE REBUILD
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN AMAZING.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO SHOWED REAL
LEADERSHIP DURING COVID.
HE KEPT THE STATE OF FLORIDA
FREE, OPEN AND SAFE.
KIDS IN FLORIDA WERE BACK IN
SCHOOL IN AUGUST OF 2020.
NO OTHER STATE WAS DOING THAT.
WHEN SO MANY OTHERS WERE
COWERING IN FEAR, HE STOOD UP
TO THE MEDIA MOB, FAUCI,